hey everyone and welcome back to episode
number 18 of the beginner to master
speedrun uh this is my first time
recording in
2024 so happy New Year let me know in
the comments if you have a chess New
Year's resolution if you're chasing a
rating goal or maybe something else let
me know would love to hear and let's hop
into things so coming into today rated
1087 uh hopefully I can break
1100 and we'll seek a 10-minute game
first opponent playing Nathaniel
wartle and I'll play uh Kings Pawn
E5 we have a Vienna which is definitely
a popular opening at uh actually across
all levels I'll play Knight F6 here the
standard move just trying to accelerate
the kingside development and we see the
Vienna Gambit which I believe I
encountered once before in the speedrun
series uh the best move here is to play
Pawn to D5 to Counterattack the center
and if white takes on E5 I can then
recapture on e4 and it's a fair
trade um now these lines do have a
tendency to get pretty imbalanced pretty
quickly uh of course depending what
white Place Queen F3 is the most popular
move as far as I know Knight of3 is also
an
alternative um but I'm pretty sure
of Gotham chess recommends this move
used to make a lot of content around the
Vienna opening Vienna Gambit and in this
position I'm going to go for
F5 uh following the same game I played a
few episodes
prior uh after I record this I'll I'll
find the game and Link it down below if
you want to see that game as well um but
F5 is a nice move to reinforce the
Knight and if white ons then I can just
recapture and life will be fine Bishop
D3 is not a move I've I don't think I've
seen before uh it does exert a bit more
pressure against the
Knight but I mean the knight's well
supported by the pawns more common is a
pawn D3 instead of Bishop
D3 so this is a first moment kind of on
my
own to try and figure things out not
relying on any opening preparation
uh move that stands out to me is Knight
C6 very simply developing and attacking
the undefended pawn especially because
white doesn't have this move or this
move or even this move yet so it might
be a bit awkward for white to defend the
pawn and go for
this white could consider
taking but then take back and grab the
bishop
pair so yeah I'm curious what White's
going to play
here
like Queen F4 might be the
only safe way to defend the pawn oh
Bishop B52
okay didn't see that coming but that
does pin the Knight also probably it's
just a better Square for the bishop
rather than uh on D3 no longer blocking
the D
Pawn so what to do
here I mean white lost a Tempo with the
bishop but
not sure how much I can actually punish
that Bishop D7 definitely comes to mind
simply break the pin Bishop D7 could
walk into some Muddy Waters like there's
takes and then takes it should be
okay and then if
takes there's some calculation where if
I take with the bishop then my F Pawn
could
hang um but yeah this is definitely
candidate move I'm also looking at
Bishop C5
here which I kind of like better just
preparing to Castle but also creating
threats of Knight F2 or Bishop
F2 let's go for this I'm also preventing
white from playing
D4 so yeah very natural very
multi-purpose move and I think it's a
common theme across a lot of the games
in this series at least from early on
I'm trying to be as efficient as
possible with developing in the opening
um and trying to be quicker than my
opponent too like sometimes if you can
develop your minor pieces more quickly
then you can be the first one to
generate
tactics and one drawback with the Vienna
is white no longer has F Pawn so this
diagonal is a bit more
exploitable white has to be super
careful here maybe a move like Knight H3
to cover
F2 white takes first okay take
back white could also consider taking on
e4 and then I'll have a choice which
Pawn to recapture
with also I didn't know what country is
this Australia okay I should be able to
identify Australian flag maybe sometimes
gets confused with New
Zealand uh okay we see Knight
G2
so white is allowing this move or this
move I mean Knight F2 Rook F1 I don't
think I accomplished
much Bishop
F2 King will have to
[Music]
move it is a nice way to take away
White's casting
rights especially white wants to play D4
next
so I probably don't want to allow D4 to
happen right away just to attack the
bishop but I'm trying to figure out a
followup like Bishop F2 King will
move and then what I move the bishop
back
maybe so I guess the question is is it
worth spending a couple of Bishop moves
to force the king to F1 or
D1 and what are my other choices like D4
doesn't look so great Queen H4 is also a
move to consider but that runs into
G3 so I think I will go for
this and then then the bishop can drop
back to
B6 so then if white plays D4 it doesn't
gain more time on the
bishop yeah let's go all the way
back it seems a bit strange like moving
the bishop couple times but I'm now
clearing F2 Square for the Knight so I
do have the threat of Knight F2 with the
fork I think white is likely to play D4
here but interesting game so
far U I like the position but I don't
think I'm like so much better maybe just
some very small types of advantages
between having the bishop hair having a
hopefully more safe King once I Castle
I think it is time to
Castle gets a rook to knce square
aligned with the White
Queen and D3
okay so yeah I think I'm pretty much
provoked to take on
C3 I don't see a more attractive option
like Knight
G5 Queen will move Knight will have to
move again I could maneuver it back to
E6
perhaps but I think trading is
fine and now one of the plans moving
forward is to use these pawns to grab
space like
we're we're in the middle game at least
I'm in the middle game like I've castled
I've
developed my Bishop I guess my my other
pieces could use some development as
well but I'd like to
formulate some plan
here and what I would really like to do
is like expand with C5 C4 D4 Etc if I
play C5 too early then it hangs
D5 so I'm going to play Bishop
E6 which okay first of all develops the
bishop but secondly it over defends this
Pawn so now that I have three
Defenders I can safely play C5 without
blundering a pawn
and usually when you have the bishop
hair you want to look for the
opportunities for Pawn breaks you also
just want to look for General tactics I
think uh yeah white just blundered a
pretty simple tactic D4 is a fork now
I'm taking a a pause here because I can
also take take and then play
D4 I'm not sure if there's a big
difference I guess if I play D4
immediately white could take
Counterattack so maybe it is better to
take take
D4 and then there's just less
counterplay also
simplify so yeah white was just not
aware of the the danger with this this
pawn
move I mean I will say white played a
pretty good game up until Bishop E3 on
move 14 and queen E4 uh blundering the
queen not sure if that was a mouse slip
or just uh succumbing to the uh the
pressure in the position but okay pretty
abrupt ending um I mean my opponent
found some like interesting moves uh I
mean Bishop D3 was maybe a small mistake
losing some time but Bishop B5 I think
was the right
followup and yeah with Bishop F2 black
is definitely for
choice and then going forward
here I think as white you just have to
find a different way to develop maybe
bishop F4 maybe a move like Knight E2 to
get the Knight here and Target the
bishop prepare this move so some better
options for white but nice game overall
and I mean for anyone that plays King's
Pawn opening is black you definitely
want to be prepared for Vienna and in
the line that I just played with D5 and
then F5 against Queen F3 three is nice
line to get a very playable
position so let's move on uh that was
the first game play the second 10minute
game rated
1095 so if I win this game I'll I think
I will break
1100 playing ninja Nicholas and we have
a
scandian so scandavian very popular
opening at the lower levels uh Queen A5
is the most common move and um
there's a few moves I like to play in
this
position if I was playing a more like
dubious aggressive repertoire uh I do
like the move B4 and there's some traps
with that line but I'm going to play in
a more solid fashion D4 is the most
principal
move and I'll go for a setup it's
another kind of opening I learned back
when I was around the age of 9 or 10 uh
my first chess coach taught me a pretty
thorough repertoire with the white
pieces and against this early
pin I'm actually trying to
remember the exact
approach uh Bishop C4 is one
option which just aims to develop and
Castle it also has a threat of maybe
some Bishop F7 under the right
circumstances but there's another idea
here to play H3
first and I think in this case H3 is a
nice move to throw in just to put the
ball in Black's Court CU if takes takes
I'm very happy to activate the queen
which we do
see uh maybe after the game I'll I'll
explain a bit more about the opening
strategy for white but going forward
from here let's complete development I
could start with Bishop C4 I think that
looks
very very nice develop and th Queen
takes F7 or Bishop takes F7
and now I can Castle or start with
Bishop
F4 sometimes when you're deciding
between two like very natural opening
moves the question to ask is what does
the opponent want to do next and one
move that black probably wants to play
is Bishop
D6 so if I start with Bishop F4 that uh
that just prevents Bishop
D6 and okay I guess maybe bishop B4 can
played but then I can castle and the
queen helps defend the
Knight so let's start with
this I'm actually realizing that we're
following uh one of the most memorable
games from my childhood which uh did not
feature G5 but I'll have a lot to show
after this game because uh yeah I do
have a story about uh what can happen
from this position but my opponent does
play G5 which
is defended by the
queen now I mean I think I just want to
move back there's not really much else
to consider like Bishop E5 would lose
material after Knight takes E5 and then
Queen also helps
attack I mean I'm looking at a move like
B4 but that only allows black to take
and attack both Bishops so
Retreat not the biggest
concession if anything black probably
has made a concession by weakening the
king side although maybe black wow black
castles Queen side so I was going to say
that yeah it's not likely black will
Castle King
side so going forward from here and if I
want to just win a pawn right
away I could take on
F7 I also kind of just want to Castle
and get my king safe first like taking
on a seven honestly I don't see anything
wrong with
it I guess there's a small concern that
black just develops and then like if I
take then Rook E8 and my queen could get
stuck actually Rook e Rook E7 would
potentially trap my
queen maybe it's okay because then I can
take with the
bishop the other thing I want to point
out here is there's
some very strong
attacking ideas with the bishop piercing
through this dark Square diagonal and
the queen also aimed towards Black's
castling
setup so I think I'm going to just
Castle
here if black gives me another chance
maybe I'll I'll then consider taking on
F7 and black does give me another chance
so yeah I don't want to take too much
time but this is definitely still an
option of course D4 is now attacked
there's another option to play Knight
E4 to Target the D6 Square which is no
longer supported by Black's
Bishop I'm also looking at ideas of
B4 like if the queen weren't here
imagine the Queen's just off the board I
would have Queen takes
C6 Pawn takes
C6 and then Bishop A6
checkmate uh I forgot what we call that
maybe bowden's mate so I'm actually
looking for ways to set that
up but I still want to be proper with
like not playing anything dubious
B4 looks nice but kind not seeing the
clear followup after Queen takes B4 then
takes takes and then takes it's not M
cuz Queen
B7 so I'm going to go for this
move rather than snagging the the pawn
uh I'm attacking so I'm not really
attacking G5 cu the queen defends G5 but
I am threatening this really nasty check
on
D6 and that would force the king to one
of these squares which would then set up
a discovery for me so spent a lot of
time in the opening but and partly
because there's a lot of things to
explain in this
position black defends F Pawn but now
it's time
to pop
in be forcing the king to C7 or
B8 now I'm actually trying to figure out
like what's the best Discovery probably
Knight takes
F7 like
attacking most of the things in the
position because Knight takes B7 attacks
the king and the queen but then King
takes
B7 so let's
take I mean this attack so King both
Rooks also leaves this pawn
undefended and now we'll take the rook
in the
[Music]
corner so I think the strategy from here
is to like keep snagging material and
then to simplify to play a bit quicker
already below four
minutes want to make sure I don't get
too low on
time but yeah the position is very nice
now two Bishops in a pretty open
position maybe still some attacking
potential like B4 is still not out of
the question because Queen takes B4 and
Rook
B1 my queen is attacked here let's just
move
it hitting the pawn on
H7 black defends and
attacks
yeah at this point I think I just want
to trade
queens and if takes I'll I'll have a
nice choice between Pawn or Bishop
takes and go for Bishop
takes which will likely lead to more
trades and this is a nice construction
uh Pawn defends a bishop Bishop defends
a pawn if Rook E8 so just safely move
away the
bishop okay Knight
E4 so let's trade
Bishops and yeah now it's time to get
the Rooks
involved attacking the Knight Knight's
going to have to find a square probably
D6 or F6 moves to D2 then I I can trap
it now I'm going to play a sneaky move
Bishop to
B3 which clears E6 Square because the
Rook really wants to go here to attack
both
Knights now I'm actually not winning a
knight immediately because black
has I mean one of these
moves but okay misses misses it if a
knight were to move to F5 I would have
played
G4 now now I'm off a full
Rook uh let's kick the
Knight we try and keep it simple
here and one of the strategies to
convert a position like this you want to
get both Rooks on the opponent's seventh
rank uh in this
case yeah black seventh
Rank and then yeah then I can start
targeting this B7
Pawn I should also note it's very useful
I have my Pawn on H3 if it was on H2 I'd
be
losing but uh okay now should be very
close to winning King has a couple
moves
checking isn't quite
mate so let's move
back and the nice thing about having the
Rooks on the seventh with the King on
the eighth rank is yeah there's so many
Ming ideas with back
rank so okay uh that concludes my
mission to reach
1100 gained a few points that game and
let me try and share a few lessons from
the opening
uh for
one when I played
H3 uh I'll start by saying that taking
it's probably a slight mistake because
black just traded off the only developed
minor piece to help me activate and the
queen is actually very good on F3 as we
saw in the game so there are a couple
other options for black uh now there's
actually a trap in this position black
has a fancy move uh Queen H5 which some
players might go for to pin the H Pawn
to the rook and also increase pressure
along the diagonal the reason why black
is basically falling into a trap here is
white can happily take the bishop lose a
rook and in this position white can trap
the queen in just two more moves and
it's basically Unstoppable if you want
to try and find the move feel free to
pause the video uh but very simply
Knight
E2 also Knight E4 probably works as well
idea to get the Knight to G3 and there's
just no way black can stop this move
Knight F6 Knight G3 White's controlling
all the squares very nice the Knight
just attacks the queen in the corner and
Bishop plays a role from C1 controlling
H6 so this is a trap I learned pretty
early on um not too often players will
fall into this because most players
don't even look to consider Queen H5 so
the the best move is probably Bishop to
H5 but from here the idea is to play
Pawn to G4 and after Bishop G6 play
Knight E5 and it's a way more energetic
and aggressive approach but white can
afford to expand because okay the king
is still fine in the center hasn't
committed to the king side and the plan
going forward from here is sometimes to
get the Knight to C4 toass the queen
usually combined with Bishop F4 there's
also cases where white can go for H4 H5
so just a more uh aggressive way to try
and challenge black from early
on so going back to what happened in the
game I do want to use this game to share
a story from my childhood cuz when I was
rated around
1300 1300 us
rating uh I forget how old I was maybe
11 years old 12 years years old I played
in a tournament where I was playing
against a 2,000 rated
player and I ended up winning from I
think it was this exact position in just
four more moves I might forget the move
order I forget if my opponent played KN
of six or castled but basically what
happened is Knight of six was played I
castled black castled like this uh so we
got a very similar position to well I
just had in this game and I played the
move Rook to D1 my opponent played the
move Queen to
B4 attacking my pawn and my Bishop both
of which are
undefended and the the clever young boy
that I was uh at yeah 11 or 12 years old
I I played a very funny move here Bishop
A6 now this is was long before the oh
know my queen or oh know my anything
sort of meme but uh can imagine that I
was maybe quietly saying to myself oh no
my bishop and I was really hoping my
2,000 rated opponent would take the
bishop because then this is
Checkmate uh but he didn't take the
bishop he played the move Knight to
B6 and this is also just his bad is
taking the bishop because I went ahead
and played Queen takes C6 uh ending the
game on the spot and this is a pretty
aesthetic mate the bishop pins the pawn
to the king the queen can't be taken
this bishop helps control B8 um now I
should note my opponent was an older man
rated um he was rated 2,000 but he had a
floor so he was playing for so many
decades that uh his rating couldn't go
below 2,000 so it's not a typical
mistake in expert player will make but
uh yeah shortly after this game maybe a
few weeks later this position appeared
in I think it was a chess column of the
Chicago
Tribune so if I can find the newspaper
clipping uh maybe I'll have to include
it in uh this video but definitely
pretty memorable to uh to upset a much
higher opponent at uh young age so going
back back let me just address what
happened in this
game uh yeah I went for Knight E4 and I
think black is already in trouble here
like maybe black can go for Knight
B6 but uh actually Knight B6 would be a
good try because The Bishop's attacked
if I play Knight D6 then Rook takes
D6 takes takes kind of mudy of
waters so yeah maybe I would just drop
back first and then prepare Knight D6
but uh yeah usually like in these
positions black should be really really
careful before castling King side
probably should have not play G5 and
gone for kingside cting was a safer
approach so anyway um let's do one more
I know that was kind of a long
explanation but hopefully some lessons
for everyone to take away and as always
if you guys have questions feel free to
leave them below uh do enjoy reading the
comments and trying to clarify anything
that might not be clear so moving on
playing Magnus uh but not Magnus Carlson
playing Magnus
FAO and we have another King's Pawn D4
the center
game so Queen takes
D4 I have encountered this opening maybe
a couple times so far the speed run uh
very simply developing the knights is
the best approach in this opening just
get the early leading develop element
with the black pieces which you can't
always do and we see E5 which uh I did
encounter one game
previously and the best move here is
Knight to G4 simply attacking the queen
and the
pawn now I think the one game I played
in this position my opponent had played
Queen F4 and just allowed me to take the
pawn uh Queen E2 is
definitely a much trickier move because
now if I take the pawn which looks very
natural to save the Knight then the
Knight will be pinned and that allows
Pawn F4 and then black is probably just
worse there losing the
knight uh so the move to go for in this
position is
D6 which at first looks self-destructive
because I'm allowing white to take with
check and now I'm temporarily down two
Pawn pawns two pawns no only down one
Pawn um but I do save the Knight and I
have the move Bishop to
E6 and after it takes I take back then I
will be down one Pawn uh but I'll be
much ahead in
development and I'm pretty sure I showed
this exact
line in the analysis of the the recent
episode where I face this opening and
I'm pretty sure the engine will say that
black is just winning after uh takes and
takes um but I'm not sure if white has a
better move here because I'm ready to
take back complete development of the
minor
pieces
so yeah it's a nice example of a
position where the material situation
doesn't really tell the whole story like
whites up a pawn but so much
compensation so much development for the
pawn more Center control the queen will
will be a Target on E2 like I'm already
threatening Knight D4 to attack the
queen and the C2 Pawn so it's going to
be hard for white to safely untangle and
develop like the queen 92 also blocks a
bishop so this is one of these openings
which I guess can be considered like a
very good Gambit for black like sacking
a pawn early
to get a massive attack yeah I don't
think I need to move this Knight like
Knight D4 immediately attacking the
queen unleashing my queen
so yeah let's go for this no mercy also
preventing Queen
B5 white doesn't have an easy
Counterattack and if I get to take on
C2 and the King has to move wherever it
ends up moving
to I'll probably have checks along the
defile maybe another Fork on
F2
if King E2 there's a pin Bishop
C4 I'm getting very much rewarded for
just having my pieces developed and on
good
squares like usually when your pieces
are in good squares the T the tactics
will
come uh in this position they're coming
very
quickly yeah so white can either get
pinned get
forked or I guess get Triple forked
I feel I feel a little bit bad for my
opponent like such savageness from the
black side but it's important lesson
like white played what is basically just
a a bad opening um I know some players
can struggle against uh against a centry
game if they don't quite know exactly
what to do
but uh yeah now it's flight really
struggling so 11 move win a nice final
position I think we'll end it there uh
it was a
Feelgood game to wrap up this episode
rated 1112 now so next goal will be to
start working my way towards
1200 I don't know if there's much to
analyze in this
game uh like generally if you do play
the center game you shouldn't play E5 I
think E5 is just not a good move even
though it is aggressive maybe some
players would fall into the Trap if
takes an F4 and then white is for Choice
here but uh yeah if you ever encounter
this as black the key move is D6 and
then it's already very good for black so
white should play Knight C3 here then
usually the plan is Bishop D2 and
castling and this opening is is
definitely playable if if white chooses
uh to go for this
plan so anyway uh we'll end it there
thanks everyone for watching if you have
questions leave them below if you like
the content like And subscribe does help
the channel and I'll see you guys soon